all right um welcome everyone to the
ddps seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and Logistics uh first please mute
yourself during the talk um but if you
have questions you are welcome to unmute
and ask questions or uh use chat room to
post your questions so that we can
address them in Q&A session at the end
um second today's ddps seminar is open
to external audience uh there for no
classified discussion is allowed uh
finally The Talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube channel okay
uh let me briefly introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host Yan
Kristoff who is an assistant professor
at card Cardiology and bioengineering in
University of California San Francisco
please uh close by from Lio where I am
uh he also serves as head of cardiac
vision
laboratory in
UCSF and Jen obtained PhD in biophysics
at University of goham um in Germany in
2014 he did uh his a post-doctoral study
at Max plank Institute uh for Dynamics
and self organizations from 2014 to 2018
and served as a staff scientist at um
Department of cardio Cardiology in
University of medical uh Center goham uh
in Germany before he comes to came to
UCSF he has oned um NIH new investigator
award dp2 um in
2022 okay today Yan will talk about
predicting heart rhythm disorders from
spatial temporal Imaging data using
artificial intelligence uh please enjoy
and expect a wonderful talk and now let
me ask a couple of questions if you
don't mind Yan um just to get to know
you better and then make this seminar
somewhat informal the first question is
obviously you are passionate about heart
or medical field in general is is there
any moment in your life when you realize
that wow this is it this is the field I
would like to commit my career uh do you
have that moment yeah sorry the question
was when was that moment when I won it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and if you can
describe that moment yeah yeah I think
um one thing that I need to say before
is that I never wanted to become a
scientist it was not not a lifelong
dream of mine when I was young I never
imagined I would be a professor or or a
scientist later on in my life I think I
I did a PhD out of curiosity because I
wanted to spend time on on on working on
quantitative biology I think that was my
interest somehow and then spending six
or seven years um or almost eight years
on this one important publication that
defined my career and that came out in
2018 in in
nature even opened up I think the way
for me to even consider becoming a
professor so it was a pretty late
decision so I was already um way into my
postto and and published um an an
impactful paper and then realized oh wow
I can actually do this if I want to I
can I can try and get a tenure track
faculty position and and keep doing this
for the rest of my life maybe even and I
think before that I I didn't have
necessarily the plan to do that um I see
but it was I think um at that point I
was definitely hooked I was really um um
intrigued by uh this type of
research um that has had buil up over
the years and uh
then you know um yeah in that moment it
became clear okay I I want to do that
that was roughly in 2018 wow you well I
don't know at some point in your
presentation today maybe you can share
what was that paper yeah I will have one
slide about that paper and it's awesome
it is a kind kind of the foundation for
for the last the second half of my talk
this paper I see I see well okay the I
have one more question if you don't mind
um obviously you're using artificial
intelligence for your research um when
were you first exposed to artificial
intelligence and decided to use that uh
in your research so I think uh the first
time I heard about um convolutional
neural networks was in the cafeteria at
Max plank in 2012 2013 you know when
Alex net and all that came out and
people talked about it but for many more
years I I didn't get my fingers on it
yeah and it was actually only during the
pandemic when our Institute shut down
when I sat at home and my student and I
we both kept talking about how we wanted
to progress and and make you know
improve certain computational methods
that we had developed and uh talked
about out encoders in unet and you know
I just tried it out and it it worked
right away and it was amazing and I
would have in my talk I will have a few
slides about exactly that awesome
awesome thank you thank you Yan stage is
yours okay thank you Yu uh for the
invitation and the introduction again my
name is Yan Kristoff I work at the um
cardiovascular research institute I'm
appointed in the division of Cardiology
here at UCSF my background is in physics
I obtained a PhD in physics and uh let
me briefly introduce my lab and you will
notice here that most people in my lab
also have a quantitative background
either computer science
physics um or electrical engineering um
and the pictures here are kind of
weighted by uh how many contributions or
important these lab members are or were
over the past years and you can notice
here Yan Liber is a central figure in my
lab he was also a PhD student in gutan
in Germany and uh came then with me to
set up the lab here at UCSF and a lot of
the work that I will talk about today it
was actually done by him uh then we were
also able to recruit um um shre last
year who has a background of physics and
computer science worked as a software
engineer and he is interested in
computer vision so he has built
important numerical methods for us and
then on the right side Daniel he is now
at CCH he was an undergraduate student
who made very important work last year
together with Yan and on the bottom um
left here tarnish who has an interest in
you know everything deeply learning and
in particular diffusion modeling and he
he did the diffusion modeling work that
I will also
show um so what what can we do as
physicists mathematicians um or
engineers in cardiology and if you are
interested in this topic a bit further I
can recommend this podcast that came out
recently in Quantum magazine that's
that's a really nice magazine I I often
read um and um Steven stroots who's an
applied mathematician from Cornell he
interviewed Flavio Fenton who's a
colleague of mine from Georgia Tech and
he since many years leads a group there
and they research um questions such as
how can we predict what the heart does
next and how can we intervene and apply
defibrillation proces in order to stop
heart rhythm disorders and they talk
about that at length and um we do very
similar research um with a slightly
different Focus we try to focus on
Imaging itself and we try to understand
the interplay between mechanics and
electrophysiology in the
heart so our community is is small but
very persistent and very active and um
very interdisciplinary we have um you
know cardiologists with an interest in
machine learning who also have a
background in engineering we have
mathematicians um applied mathematicians
Engineers physicists and they all have
the different views and and approaches
um but we together we we meet quite
frequently at least once a year this was
for instance a meeting in 2018 which
also I think helped me to make this
decision that I want to stay in Academia
and that I want to give it a try to keep
pursuing these these projects and this
these research topics that I'm currently
working on it was at the um kitp at
Santa
Barbara and um I would say that these
people um like us who who have a
quantitative background are a a very
small group in this huge Arena of
cardiologists and biologists and
physiologists who um Research heart
rhythm disorders or heart disease in
general and there's roughly an even
distribution between you know
mathematicians physicist engineering
computer scientists how to how to say
who who dominates this field I would say
last year we organized um a meeting or a
mini Symposium at um a s conference and
this year again we will meet at a s
conference so this is also something
that we we often participate in or or
organize and the people who come there
um are regulars people who who've done
who've come to these meetings since many
many years they they keep showing
up so the the heart is an
electromechanical pump that is something
that I uh need to introduce first the
most important property of cardiac
muscle cells and you see here one on the
left side is that they are electrically
excitable they um their their
transmembrane put potential under goes
variations over time um that serves
that's that's a way of communicating uh
for these cells um and um these changes
are referred to as Action potentials you
see there on the right side three curves
the first one the green one is the
action potential as soon as a cardom
myosite experiences such an action
potential it opens intracellular storage
for calcium and the is then released
into the cell and the calcium kind of
fues the contration of the cell so the
contraction follows the the action
potential is is elicited by um the
action
potential then uh this electrical
excitation overall on the global scale
in the heart triggers and orchestrates
the heartbeat we have in our heart
multiple centers um the sinoatrial node
and a backup node and in there are cells
that beat autonomously roughly one time
per second and then they shoot out
electrical excitation through a cable
and then through through a branch of
other cables into the main um heart
muscle tissue that is shown here and
this heart muscle tissue consists of
roughly five billion
cardiomyocytes and once this electric
exitation uh reaches the end of these
so-called Pinger fibers um they exit at
these sides excite the first kyom
myosite or small group of kyom myoides
and they pass on this excitation to
their neighboring cells and so via a
diffusive process this excitation then
is uh propagated through the entire
cardiac muscle and this
exitation um propagates through the
muscle tissue at a speed of roughly 1
meter per second so it's relatively
fast then atrial fibrillation and
ventricular fibrillation are the two
most severe forms of heart rhythm
disorders there are many different
flavors of heart rhythm disorders but
those are the most prominent ones
because they either affect many many
people or they are highly deadly so age
refibrillation affects the pre- chambers
of the heart uh the Atria um that can be
a chronic um condition that you can have
for many weeks or months before you have
your electric procedure to get rid of at
refibrillation um and uh they at
refibrillation itself is very
problematic because it can cause heart
failure or induce ventricular
fibrillation which then affects the main
Chambers and is immediately
life-threatening however when trick
fibrillation can also occur on its own
without a fibrillation it can occur
spontaneously and uh you often have um
sadly these reports here um that you can
that you I can update the slide every 3
four months another celebrity dies from
Sudden cardiac death it is very common
and uh it affects really people at all
ages it can sometimes affect um people
who do Sports
um especially in professional sports um
at a very young age it can affect people
with genetic defects at a young age but
of course it becomes more and more
prevalent the older you
become um physicists describe these
electrical wave phenomena um with
partial differential equations I will
have a few slides about that and here
are some um reviews about um that and
which which nicely summarize the work
that has been done in our field
um in short um you can see here an
electrocardiogram at the top that
describes uh a sudden onet of
ventricular fibrillation so the most
severe and most deadly form of the heart
rhythm disorder on the left side you can
see the QRS complex here uh which
corresponds to a heartbeat this here
corresponds to the Atria Contracting
this to the ventricles Contracting and
you see three heartbeats before all of a
sudden out of nowhere this ventricular
fibrillation sets on and we associate
with this episode here three computer
simulations that um describe the spacial
temporal dynamics of the electrical
waves that determine the heartbeat
during these three stages here so the
normal heart rhythm is caused by um a
plane wave that really originates down
there where the Pinger fibers inject the
excitation into the heart muscle then
this wave propagates upwards and needs
to be reinitiated um by the sinus nor
and here what happens here is that this
wave becomes perturbed and um under goes
um um a transition into this spiraling
or rotating State and we refer to this
wave or form here as a scroll wave a
scroll because it's it's cured up like
that and this score wave can even
further degenerate into spatial
temperary chaos which is shown here on
the right side and these computer
simulations um are supposed to
illustrate what we think happens inside
of the heart muscle during these
different
stages we can model um cardiac cells in
that sense as um relaxational
oscillators or nonlinear oscillators and
you see here an example of a an quite
old mathematical model for such a
relaxational oscillator the fitun auma
model and um in in such a model you have
two equations one stands for the
excitation one for the refractoriness
and they kind of compete with each other
whenever the excitation goes up the
refractor also
go the excitation and in phas space you
then have this Behavior here that most
of the time um the cell is in the fixed
point but if you perturb it slightly if
the cell receives excitation from one of
the neighboring cells then youur this um
oscillator here over this um um
separatrix and you see an Excursion
through face space which corresponds
over time to an action
potential
this mathematical modeling of of this
electrical activity can in principle be
divided in either this synthetic bottom
up approach where you um um measure all
ions in in cells or ION channel and and
their contribution to the cell transm
potential and and iron fluxes to the
cells or an analytical top down or
phenomenological approach such as the
paguma approach where you kind of mimic
the behavior of action potentials using
these relaxational oscillators and of
course over the years this was back then
in the 50s um many many different models
were developed and we kind of
distinguish them into either these ionic
very detailed models which are
computationally expensive or
phenomenological models which are cheap
and and easy to implement but also are
less realistic or any hybrid version
between these two extreme forms and this
is kind of The Sweet Spot um for
instance defend and Karma model is one
model is used widely and there are many
other models which are which consist of
fewer um equations and fewer parameters
but sufficiently many parameters so that
you can um recapitulate the most
important dynamics of the heart so if
you then connect all these oscillators
in a tissue you have then nonlinear
waves of electrical exitation which
propagate the tissue and here this is a
cell automaton and you see if if you
excite one cell p on the excitation to
neighboring cells and eventually this
wave dies out at the boundary because
it's followed by this refractory wave
that prevents further reexcitation of
the tissue and this is important this is
the most important property of our heart
that um the excitation is supposed to
occur once a second and that it's also
supposed to die out so that the heart
can relax
again um the big analogy is for instance
a firefront you have excitable tissue
that is maybe dry grass um the the
excitation wave itself is a firefront
and the refractory part is the fuel has
has burned and is gone and the fire can
turn around and re exite or reignite the
the
forest now in a continuous medium we can
nicely simulate this uh with PD and and
in this case this is a special form of
reaction diffusion system you can see
here again this is a diffusive term
these are local reaction uh local
reaction terms that describe the
excitability of the tissue so again you
have a rest State and a threshold and
once you perturb this this oscillator
over this threshold you have this
excursion the action potential and then
due to the diffusion you have here this
wave that propagates outwards and then
dies out at the system
boundaries now cardiologists they try to
measure these wave phenomena in
patients however there are many
limitations um in terms of how how
practical it is to to access the tissue
to to measure and obtain recordings from
from patients um the gold standard
currently is to use um so-called
catheter mapping so catheters are
inserted into a patient this procedure
is called minimally invasive but
nevertheless it is invasive um and then
under anesthesia um cardiologist record
here electric activity from these tips
of these um catheters and there are many
different designs and shapes but what it
is in the at the end of the day it is a
point BYO measurement and it's a lengthy
measurement it's time consuming because
they have to reposition the catheter and
you have to assume that this Rhythm that
this patient is in is stable as soon as
it is irregular and chaotic they cannot
obtain reliable measurements so it is
really only applicable in patients that
have a stable abnormal
them nevertheless you can obtain very
nice maps from patients this here is a
patient that um is in in a procedure um
and and has ventricular takic cardia you
can see here uh two maps one was
obtained at the at the epicard the
outside of the heart and one was
obtained on the endoc card of the heart
on the inner surface and these two
recordings were obtained kind of
simultaneously and and are synchronized
in time you see this kind of rotating
wave pattern and this is a pan that
shouldn't be there that is abnormal and
that causes irregular beats or irregular
contractile function and it's it's
circulating around this area here where
there's presumably a scar in this
patient so this patient had a myio
cardio infar and then what can happen is
that these waves get caught there and
they kind of circulate around these
infacts however there can also be much
much more complex rhythms and you can
see here an excised pick hard on the
left side side that was excised at the
master University in the Netherlands and
they they you can see here very nicely
how chaotic um this this heart contracts
during the Trier fibrillation and on the
right side here this is a rabbit heart
that we have imaged in our lab um during
VRI fibrillation that we induced
electrically and I will slow down this
video from you now and I hope it plays
um um smoothly you can see now overlay
action potential waves in pink which
correlate with this mechanical
contraction that the heart exhibit
during when trigger fibrillation so here
we have a measurement of these chaotic
wave patterns um uh obtained on the
surface of the Heart Another example um
how fast and how irregular the
contractions can become and this is a
very extreme example of a pig heart
filating there's almost no contractor
activity anymore and this is why vation
is so dangerous there's no blood flow
any
longer so we can in a laboratory setting
excise hearts and keep them alive for
roughly one day and do imaging
experiments with these Hearts we peruse
them with a liquid called tyroid
solution which is essentially water plus
salts plus sugar and oxygen we keep the
pH level at a level where it's supposed
to be and then we apply something that
is called retrograde perfusion we pump
blood uh this this solution here
retrograd into the heart closes the
valves and then goes into the coronary
vessels and perfuses the heart and
therefore can be kept alive for many
many hours so this is our um Imaging
setup that we have built here at UCSF
you can see the center pieces here this
Imaging chamber um inside of that
chamber is this liquid and the and the
intact heart the heart can also be seen
here in 12 video um um images uh these
images are acquired simultaneously at
very high speeds 500 images per second
by these cameras that are here on this
table and on the left side you can see a
commercial ultrasound system that is
also integrated into this Imaging system
and this ultrasound system records
threedimensional volumetric images of
the
heart I hope this plays well uh you can
see here a rabbit heart beating in our
tank this is the same Rabbit Heart and
this is the ultrasound transducer here
at the bottom it's a 2d Matrix array
transducer that produces between 25 and
100 volumes per
second again this is a um a drawing here
of of of these different camera images
these cames cameras are
calibrated and we were able to
reconstruct the entire surface of the
ventricles with 12 cameras that are
synchronized and
calibrated um and then we cross-register
the Optical reconstructions that we can
make uh um with the cameras with the
ultrasound data so that we have
structural Imaging data plus functional
Imaging data that we acquire optically
because optically we do not only image
the surface of the heart but we add
florescent dieses and these florescent
dieses are then excited with this green
light on the left side you can see here
um 48 LEDs that are also integrated into
this Imaging setup and they illuminate
the heart from all sides even ly and
excite florescent die which then emits
um particular wavelengths more in the
red um and this uh this emission light
then carries the information that we can
measure and from which we can extract
action potential
waves and this here now is one such
measurement during the normal heartbeat
sinus rhythm you can see these are 3D
reconstructions relatively High
resolutions the heart contracts and you
will also notice if you watch closely
that there's a slight decrease in
intensity I will slow this video now
down again we have added voltage sensor
the first die and this die indicates
action potential waves or voltage
changes I don't know if you can see that
on Zoom you may or may not see it um I
can see it pretty well on my screen
there's a slight decrease and I will now
um amplify this decrease this is the uh
routine processing step that we do we
extract the signal by simply amplifying
it over time and you can see here the
action potential wave front in Black so
this activation occurs in in multiple
sites in the ventricles due to this
Pinger fiber system that eject ejects
this excitation in several sides we can
also measure then accordingly mechanical
strain what you can see here is the area
change and then red that is a decrease
in area change and blue is with dilation
or increase so that we are able to
measure this is the result of many many
years of work um this technique is
called Optical mapping and it is uh
almost 50 years old um in the 70s the um
the first measurements were done with
with voltage sensitive frent dies and
people demonstrated that it is possible
to measure action potential waves and
then this technique really had a had its
Heyday in the 90s where people using a
single camera were able to to provide
the first measurements of ventricular
fibrillation and these wave phenomena in
in in hearts and isolated Hearts um
however they performed these
measurements with pharmacologically
contraction inhibited hearts and in the
past 10 years I and other people have um
U contributed or developed algorithm
with which it is possible to track the
heart and extract these sickness from
beating hearts and so there are I would
say um 99% of all Publications that were
done many thousands of Publications Pati
were done with these pharmacologically
contraction inhibited hearts and since
2016 17 roughly there are now more and
more Publications coming out where this
compound called blist Statin is is left
out of the experiment and we can now
study for the first time mechanics and
electrics at the same time and also um
what is kind of rare in our field is
that people use multicamera systems such
as our system in order to reconstruct
the 3D surface of the heart so right now
as far as I know this measurement that I
showed to you is the only one of its
kind this is now a measurement of
ventrier fibrillation you can see that
the heart is moving very slightly um
almost not at all and um you can
appreciate here also these um chaotic
wave patterns that uh we can observe now
on the across the surface of the heart
they are spiraling they're rotating and
that now backs the question what what is
this what what are these Dynamics what
is cardiac fation this is a a very old
question that has fascinated many people
for many many years and in the 60s um a
chemist a physicist and chemist who with
who I also worked in in gting and in
Germany um came up with this hypothesis
okay I know that in the so-called Bel of
satinsky chemic rection I see these
spiral waves and these spiral waves must
be related to cardiac fibrillation SP
waves are ubiquitous in nature there are
many many different examples in either
biology or in chemistry this is here an
example where I saw them here in the
wild in
California and there are many many other
examples where you can observe spiral
waves in nature and these are all
reaction diffusion systems turns out
they have all very similar equations um
different compounds that become depleted
or or regenerated and that creates these
these patterns
so how can these rotating um patterns be
created or how how do they emerge in the
heart in particular there were very
early experiments roughly 100 years ago
where somebody cut out a piece of a
heart and stimulated in such a way that
they were able to see rotating waves
were circulating in this in this ring of
cardiac muscle tissue and that was for a
very long time than the the central
hypothesis there must be these circuits
in the heart that sustain this
persistent activation but since
Valentine krinsky we uh also believe
that this happens here in this tissue so
if you activate cells in such a fashion
here that there's an open end of the
wave that can emerge um in in the real
heart or if you keep this part here
temporarily refractory activate this
part then this following
happens this wave is able to rotate
around its open end and this is a SP
fire wave and and the central mechanism
in the heart that drives heart rithm
disorders Taki arthas this year is a
cardiac cell culture where you can
appreciate that this wave pattern really
uh exists in in 2D at least and this is
a recording made by Flavio Fen and Ilia
usak at at Georgia Tech they really see
here a voltage and a calcium rotational
wave um that is stationary and then
degenerate into more complex wave
patterns over
time these wave patterns are surpris
surprisingly robust they can be
sustained in highly anisotropic and very
complex geometries you can see a despite
the in the Atria there's there's varying
uh fibers and and and complex geometry
but this rotating wave uh can live on
such a
substrate depending on the parameter and
depending on your genetic makeup and so
on and so forth physiological conditions
these waves can have all sorts of
different shapes and that is Illustrated
here in this uh three variable model
depending on these two parameters alone
you can create various different
dynamical regimes of these
waves then the mechanisms how these
waves can break up is is is is manifold
there are many different mechanisms but
one is for instance that these waves can
interact with themselves this Leading
Edge here correct es into the tail of
its of its own ta arm and then can break
up this wave this is also shown here um
there are these breathing um
instabilities that can cause then
further down the road Cascade into chaos
this is another illustration this wave
propagates you through tissue that is
damaged the white tissue is is is not
supporting this this wave that well and
it accordingly can lead to heterogenity
and breakup so heterogen gen it in
general can promote
arithmos and now in 3D um it becomes a
little bit more complicated but even in
entirely homogeneous media without any
um heterogenity in the substrate you can
have a route into chaos you can see here
a scroll wave and the blue line is a
filament of the scroll wave that's the
center around which this wave rotates
and due to certain instabilities these
these filaments can interact with
themselves and break up and then cause
such a complex turbulent wave pattern
which is also the underlying mechanism
for this wave pattern here on the right
side so now to the part where Ai and
data modeling can help us to better
understand or diagnose hm disorders we
have applied various um generic deep
learning techniques um such as unet for
instance um to solve certain problems in
in our field one um application for
instance is um that um people are
interested in localizing these regions
here around which these waves um spiral
or rotate because um you can imagine
that if you would remove this point then
this this Center here would stop
shooting out these ways and accordingly
this part of the heart would go maybe
eventually back into sinus rhythm so
getting rid of these points of these
face singularities is a way of
defibrillating a heart and um therefore
automatically tracking these points is
important and it was um already shown in
the the late 90s that you can
automatically identify these points you
um embed this this temporary signal
using a hi transform and then in these
resulting phas maps you can compute the
the gradient of the face and whenever
you compute a circular integral over the
gradient around such a phase Singularity
you get a discontinuity and these
discontinuities can then serve as a
detection mechanism to to track
automatically face singularities through
or across the
tissue however in practice um it is not
easy to do that um even with high
resolution data due to noise and other
artifacts um it is sometimes uh you end
up with furious pH singularities or um
measurements that are simply not robust
so you can see here in a in a computer
simulation this works pretty nicely but
if you imagine you work with catheter
mapping and you have spar measurements
um only um here on these points or along
these points then the underlying
measurement is is far from the ground
throughs and accordingly the
trajectories of these fa envelope points
they can deviate quite significantly
here shown on the right side from from
the ground
throughs so we thought this is a perfect
problem for a unit or out encoder or
lstm uh version of a unit to to process
such data we trained uh such a network
here encoding decoding convolution new
network with a sequence or a video of of
such data so this here on the left side
are voltage sensitive measurements and
then on the right side we either Target
discrete points directly or we compute
face maps and in these face Maps then um
face singular
points and uh we saw that this network
um um can do this easily with only five
snapshots uh five measurements uh from
the activity even sparse measurements
can provide you a face map so it can
successfully cross predict these face
maps from electrical measurements and
they are not far away from the ground
tooth and they can do that with less
than 10% of the spatial information so
that showed us immediately how powerful
new networks can be for certain
applications in our field um and you can
com compare that previous um success or
measurement with maybe this example here
uh once you've seen this image here on
the right side it will also be much
easier for you to anticipate what this
sparse measurement of that image might
be and then what the network here does
is it has seen so many examples of these
dynamics that it can easily recover um
the underlying Dynamics from it um the
overall um prediction accuracy of course
goes down the sparer and the more noisy
um um the data gets um but overall we
would still be able to identify here
these facing GL points and therefore
these rotational patterns across the
surface of of tissue we have then
applied it to our Optical mapping
recordings you can see a ventricular
fation and a Pickard and we can train
this network either on this data or on
simulation data and then um um instantly
compute these facing L points if we were
to compute these facing points for from
our recordings we would need a very long
much much longer recording at least
maybe 1 second whereas over here only a
few milliseconds are sufficient to
compute these
points most interestingly to us was that
we were able to train it on simulation
data as shown you on the left side and
then apply it to experimental data as
shown on the right side even though this
data here or these dynamics that are
shown here are threedimensional dynamics
and they are what what we see here is
the surface wave pattern of a
three-dimensional wave pattern that
evolves within the heart muscle over
here on the in contrast the 2D
simulations that we performed are really
only 2D so they're completely different
Dynamics kind of and of course these
computer models also not um not fitted
to this real um wave pattern here but
nevertheless it's sufficient for the
network to perform relatively well so
you can see here um um that if we train
on simulation data and apply to
simulation data we have a very high
accuracy and we can train on pick data
and rabit data meaning that we used
isolated Hearts from either pick or
rabbit um still get a very high accuracy
and if we only train on simulations and
apply it to pick or rabbits we still get
a decent angular
accuracy the next problem that we then
tried to address was the following we we
can image currently with our frent dice
the 3D wave pattern um or the the the
projection of this wave pattern on the
surface of the heart but these dyes do
not really penetrate uh they do
penetrate into the heart muscle but the
the light coming out of the heart muscle
cannot reach the surface because the
heart is too thick and therefore we
don't really know what's going on
underneath the heart surface and we do
not have measurements of intrical fation
in 3D we have computer simulations but
not real
data and we tested now in in these
generic toy model scenarios um how well
um convolutional neural network would be
able to extrapolate the
three-dimensional wave pattern from
two-dimensional surface measurements so
you can see on the left side a 3D scroll
wave um pattern that shoots out waves
towards the surface and on the right
side you see whatever we can see on the
surface so we're kind of pretending this
is our experimental setting and uh then
trained a neural network to predict from
2D surface measurements so this here is
the surface layer of this bike peeled
off and fed into the neural network and
we used five time steps so five of these
snapshots and the target then was the
full 3d
pattern and this here is a
reconstruction so you can see that works
pretty well when we look at it from
above you see this The Superficial
layers they are all reconstructed pretty
well but then if we zoom in and and look
at it uh in more detail we see that the
the construction accuracy decreases with
depth so the surface layers here they
are sharp and crisp and also accurate
but the deeper you go the more it fuzzes
out and becomes less
accurate we use diffusion models in the
same way um training them to predict
either from only the surface top surface
or from the bottom surface or from both
surfaces the three-dimensional wave
pattern and saw that they perform
similarly to a simple unit
architecture um however um um if you
provide them with more data they they
can perform much better than unit so we
did a mistake kind of we we tried to
reproduce the same results as that we
obtained with the unit and with unit we
saw that there's a saturation if you
provide unit more than five frames let's
say 10 frames 20 30 50 the the network
doesn't become better at it um and we
then also stopped with the diffusion
model with five frames because we
thought well it didn't get any better
with the unit model but um here uher had
all were able to show that if you
actually use more data and provide more
data to the diffusion model and with
more data I mean um you know these five
samples that we extracted were five um
snapshots of one rotation of such a SP
wave of course you need to take into
account how fast do these waves
propagate to the surface and and so on
and so forth and here if you have much
much more data that goes maybe Beyond
one period of of the SP wave then you
can actually decrease this error um
quite a bit nevertheless you can see
that the deeper you go the greater the
uncertainty and and error becomes and
therefore this it maybe not the best
approach to try to extrapolate these
complicated chaotic Dynamics from
surface observations alone and um um
therefore another approach is needed and
this is something that I would discuss
now in the second part of the talk um
before I jump into that I wanted to
mention that um einthoven here in 1903
came up with this invention the
electrocardiogram and since then the
electrocardiogram has had tremendous
success in cardiology everyone uses it
it's very cheap It's very effective and
you can immediately even at home
yourself can assess the state of your
heart you can say okay my heart is
beating normally or oh something is
something is is wrong I need to see a
doctor and it's it's very cheap so
therefore um I think people have never
really dared to come up with
alternatives to this um the problem with
the electrocardiogram and all electrical
measurements is what I just showed to
you you can not access the entire heart
and you cannot really visualize what's
going on beneath the surface of the
heart and this focus on the
electrocardiogram has maybe kind of
Blended us and and prevented us from
from looking at what's already there the
the heart beatss the heart contracts and
it's visible we can use an ultrasound
machine we can use MRI and we see the
contractions of the heart and we can
analyze them and so therefore we could
now ask the question can we actually
calculate the electrophysiology or the
action potential wave patterns that
trigger the contractions of the heart
from the motion of the heart and this is
here now Illustrated in these three
idealized
ventricular um B ventricular um elect
mechanic simulations you can see on the
left side this plane wave here induces a
very distinct contractile pattern that
is distinct from the contract pattern
that is induced by two rotating waves or
by five or more rotating waves so it
should be possible to to compute
something like
that but we didn't have the measurement
data that could actually um um give us
this this this certainty or this
experimental evidence that
would support this hypothesis and here
in our setup we have now such data that
motivates this even further you can see
here this wave that propagates across
the ventricles of a rabbit heart and
this wave induces a contraction that is
highly correlated with the action
potential Wave It's not that everything
contracts at once it is really that the
contractor activity sets on and and and
follows the the action potential R and
then the two questions that we had
initially and we still have and trying
to addresses is this sufficient
information to compute electric
activation if you look at this mesh here
is that enough and is this mapping
between electrics and mechanics
unique um these three images here show
you how closely correlated that actually
is the action potential wave here
propagating from the left to the right
um induces contractor activity over
there and because of contracts over
there which also shown here in the
strain rate image um tissue is being
pulled towards the wave and that tissue
dilates as a consequence and this is a
very characteristic phenomenon that we
observe um over and over now in our
experiments and this wavefront here
between dilating strain and contractor
strain is following the action potential
wfront there's a small delay that is
typical for cardiac tissue and it it
propagates in the same direction so
there is really experimental evidence
that um justifies this approach
and there are more observations that we
made in the past so here you can see um
waves with your this is a recording that
we made with the phone um mechanical
waves that propagate through the heart
this heart was treated with cardioplegic
solution um and therefore the activity
was pretty um um slow down and uh but
you can see this wave phenomena this now
is the paper that I mentioned in the
beginning I um studied this uh
mechanical deformation pattern um in in
the in the ventricular walls in computer
simulations and then also made
recordings measuring here voltage Kum
and strain and you see here a clockwise
rotating pattern in all of these three
quantities so down here we I was able to
compute face singularities that indicate
the rotational centers of these waves um
for voltage kisum and
strain and there are um there we we
published in two papers that um one is a
physics based approach is a deep
learning based approach in which we try
to compute now electrical waves from
mechanical deformation and I will
briefly talk about this year mainly
because I wanted to highlight how much
better deep Learning Works actually so
the first approach is a data simulation
approach we say system one is the system
that we want to measure system two is a
virtual replication of that system we
introduce sensors in the system that we
want to measure and control Us in the
virtual replication of that system and
drive the system with the measurement
data that we have available eventually
from system one so we can see here two
excitable media excitable systems system
one exist system two and there's a
coupling term here and this coupling
term is really only the difference
between the states um of of these
oscillators over here versus here and
because videos sometimes explain that
much better than 1,000 words you can see
that here this computer simulation is
coupled to this SE culture measurement
over here um and this constantly
receiving input from this from these
sensors over here by by the controllers
that are placed in this domain and you
see that this uh simulation co-evolves
with the cell culture and we adapted
this principle and and modified it a
little bit uh we have we we know that um
based on our measurements these
electrical waves induce also mechanical
waves therefore it might be possible to
do exactly this slightly modified
instead of having in your control full
term comparison between the two
electrical States you can now compare
either an electrical and a mechanical
State or the mechanical state of system
one with the mechanical state of system
two and modify the electrics in such a
way that the mechanics of the second
system match the mechanics of the first
system um so that's shown here we have
sensors in in our drive system or the
the first system that we want to measure
which measure mechanics strain for
instance strain rate and they mod the
controllers in the electrics of the
second system so here we have a spiral
wave that induces um mechanical
contractions red is contraction blue is
station uh we added some noise to it and
then observed that and induced Electric
exitation in these locations here
wherever contraction occurred with a
negative electromechanical delay and you
can see then that over time this system
becomes synchronized with the first
system and therefore we have a
reconstruction of the dynamic in the
first system based on a mechanical
measurement and then we were relatively
happy that this also works for very
complex wave pattern so you can see here
a comparison of the reconstructed wave
pattern from mechanics with the original
wave pattern the topology is very
similar however there were quite
significant differences still so we were
happy about an 80% reconstruction
accuracy but all of that was um kind of
um killed with deep learning because it
worked right away much better using
simply an autoencoder for this problem
so we trained an autoencoder and a unet
um with um pairs of mechanical
deformation patterns with electrical
exitation patterns that cause these
deformation patterns here you see a
spiral wave pattern that induces
together with M fiber anisotropy this
anisotropic spiral wave like mechanical
deformation pattern a focal wave pattern
a more complex wave pattern and we use
20,000 samples of such um um pairs to
then um estimate um um um electrical
waves from mechanics with unseen data so
the network architecture again was a
simple encoder decoder we analyze
displacements um X and Y displacements
in 2D which could either be with ref
with respect to an undeformed mechanical
state or any arbitrary mechanical State
or the previous mechanical state of the
system
and saw that this works uh pretty uh
well after a short uh period of training
and after a few
EPO this is um um an example of 3D
Dynamics very very turbulent Dynamics um
these Dynamics induce tiny mechanical
deformations here which were analyzed by
the network and this is the
Reconstruction it's visually
indistinguishable from the original
Dynamics so the complexity of the wave
patterns really no limitation
and you can see here on the right side
those are Vortex filaments that were
computed either from the original wave
pattern or from the reconstructed wave
patterns in black and in Gray and they
perfectly um
overlap so now the question is how is
this applicable in patients can we use
this to reconstruct electrical activity
in a patient who is there in in the
clinic and and doing such a procedure
here you can see this heart is beaing
abnormally this patient has a
ventricular t cardia
and at the center is the tip of a
catheter so this person performs this
procedure here of mapping the patient
and spends many many minutes maybe a
full hour to obtain a 2d map of the
electrical activity but since we are
measuring this at the same time this
ultrasound recording we could instantly
provide this um activation map if we are
able to um uh compute it from the
mechanics so we perform computer
simulations again idealized by in
tricular computer simulations which
retain Massif fiber architecture that is
necessary in in electromechanic
simulations this m fiber um architecture
determines how the heart contracts but
also how the waves propagate then one
issue was that we needed roughly uh at
least 10,000 or maybe ideally 50,000
training samples how do you get that
many training samples in computer
simulations that are usually
traditionally very expensive so we used
sxes which is a particle hydrodynamics
um uh framework um because it provided
us sufficient speeds and we were able to
compute one um episode here in less than
10 minutes and could therefore over the
course of a few days um simulate enough
um training samples and then this
problem becomes the following here we
have threedimensional Point cloud of
three-dimensional motion vectors which
describe the motion and de formation of
the ventur the target is um a static
voltage wave pattern again we have many
many different examples of these pairs
and um the uh unit that we there then
use is a sparse res unit we use this
minkovsky engine here to process
unstructured grid data and convert it
into a format that this unit understands
the input are five frames um describing
five states of the the mechanical
deformation state of the heart uh that
could in principle be extracted from
Mound recordings or MRI recordings and
the target is then the electrical
morphology of the wave pattern in the
computer simulations we varied four
different electrical models which all
produce very distinct uh electrical wave
patterns with four constitutive equ laws
for the mechanics and then um have
randomized initial conditions model
parameters the geometries of the tissues
and either induce focal or reentrant
waves you can see here the different
anatomical geometries that also have an
influence on the fiber architecture and
created 1,000 different geometries plus
fiber architectures and then varied our
initial conditions so we for instance
stimulated the heart at the bottom at
the front or at the back in random
positions or induced these different um
spiraling wave patterns also in random
positions and you can see here how these
different Electrical uh models produce
very different uh um um qualitatively
different um quantitatively different
wave patterns again this these are four
examples this is maybe a more realistic
uh um simulation that would be more
comparable to what's what's happening in
a patient who has a BT episode and this
is a more idealized computer
simulation we also in
space varied the model parameters
accounting for space spal
heterogenity and overall varied um
randomized uh more than 15 I think
parameters and also included scar tissue
or heterogenity so here in red these
parts of the tissue did not contract or
did not conduct um and then we um were
happy to see that this works we can
actually train such a network this is is
the ground truth electrical wave pattern
that induced this mechanical deformation
pattern they are shown on the left this
was the input to the network and this is
the prediction it works for focal wave
patterns we can compute now um these
activation Maps here from these a
sequence of predictions of electrical
wave patterns this is an activation map
that was directly computed from the
sequence of electrical wave snapshots
and then from this mechanical
deformation we computed this sequence
down here and this activation map and
it's it's very similar and you can now
compute from the mechanical deformation
of the heart these electrical activation
Maps which are important for
cardiologists because sometimes they're
interested in where do these ectopic
beads these additional undesired beads
come from it works for reant wave
activity also pretty well and um these
are the different um accuracies that we
achieved how much more time do I have do
I need to run through the remaining
slides or how many how many more slides
have it's 11 now and uh I might run out
of time um yeah maybe you can wrap up um
okay I will try to wrap up next next
five minutes yeah next five minutes yeah
okay good so this is here an example
where um the heart includes also scar
tissue and the prediction um
nevertheless uh Works quite well this is
very important because most patients
actually do have um myio cardio infarcts
and and accordingly heterogenity
and and scars and if this method
wouldn't work in the presence of scars
then it would be useless
probably so now how do we translate that
to the clinic uh we we showed in
computer simulations that this works but
that can also that doesn't mean that it
needs to work with patients um we have
tried to apply a network that was only
trained on simulation data on such data
here on the right side and that
obviously did not work and our approach
now is to um generate training data in
our experimental setup with isolated
parts and then uh see how well that
could perform maybe on on real patient
data or fine-tune um models subsequently
um further down the road with with all
of these different types of data so this
is the experimental data that we have it
is really high quality electromechanical
data of um Hearts we know um stimulate
the hearts in such a way that we have
many many different stimulation sites
and of course responding mechanical
deformation pattern this is here just
the optical recording um the red vectors
indicate the mechanical deformation but
we also have of course transal um um
mechanical data from the
ultrasound and this is shown here this
is raw ultrasound data a segmentation
that deforms based on the 3D motion
tracking that we perform this is
corresponding Target then on the surface
at least of the electrical activity and
we are currently in the process of fully
automating these these experiments uh in
order to be able to generate 50,000
training sampers or many many thousands
of training sampers so that means that
we need to be able to go into these
recordings pick a certain uh frame and
then extract the frames reconstructed in
3D uh cross register these two
recordings and extract here the
corresponding data and um fuse the data
together
um we've seen in other examples that in
terms of generalization we can train the
sorry we can train the the model in in
the simulation domain and leave out one
of the electrical models and it still
works pretty well we have applied it to
significantly different geometries um it
also works in those we have uh borrowed
data from from collaborators who use
finite element modeling instead of SP
modeling that we use to train the model
and it also works sufficiently well and
I think that if we improve our of our
methodology it should be possible to
reconstruct over our um exitation waves
from mechanical deformation now the big
question is um how do we get that uh to
work in our xivo Imaging setup and um
let me jump through the last slides here
we
showed um that for instance in these
two-dimensional s cultures we can apply
a a a model that was trained only on
simulation data on these um experimental
measurements and get reconstructions
that make us hopeful that this could
actually work in
practice um as an Outlook of course we
would like to use um this data not only
for
predicting one thing from another but
also maybe to evolve um and um obtain a
data driven model of of the heart based
on these this experimental data that we
able to generate now in our setup so
we've used diffusion modeling and saw
that diffusion modeling can be used to
evolve card Dynamics we can generate
shapes and waves um that look like
ventricles and re-entrant circuits and
I'm sure that we will also be able to
generate beading Hearts U maybe even
driven by the data that we we have now
in our experimental setup so that adds
now a third pillar to to our um set of
tools that we we have the conventional
computer simulations and now maybe
hopefully soon also datadriven modeling
of cardiac electr mechanics so and I
hope I didn't exceed too
much thank you very much for your
attention very nice very nice thank you
so much for the interesting talk Yan um
enjoyed it a lot let's have
a Q&A sessions um so well I first want
to introduce you to Rob robot Blake at
Lawrence liore um Rob are you still
there yeah I'm still here oh cool um so
Rob has been you know working on the
computational model for uh
cardiovascular system um we we have some
computational to Rob do do you want to
introduce yeah yeah hi hi Yan um I
worked with Natalia for a long long time
and wrote All Our Song
right uh so we have cardioid here um
that can do a whole bunch of cardiac
simulation stuff you might be interested
in I also have Melody that lets you take
anything off cellml and quickly generate
code for it to run in chaste or whatever
simulator you want and I have a really
cool data set um that you'll want to get
access to we did a whole bunch of
simulations of just ventricular and then
recorded pseudo ECGs and then able to
train a neural network to go from the
ECG to transmural maps on the
aa16 mhm nice okay yeah we should
definitely talk yeah awesome all right
let's have a Q&A
sessions um if you have any questions
yeah please don't hesitate just unmute
yourself and ask questions I I can I can
start um so you
know you said that the measurement can
be only done on the on the surface right
um in order to um fill the Gap you
relying on the computational model but
every patient has a different shape of
the heart probably
and how do you deal with that I mean
it's no building those computational
model um one of them will take some time
and if you have a patient with a
different shape of the heart do you
quickly do you parameterize the the
heart computation model so that quickly
change the the shape of the heart and
run the run the heart model good
question I think I'm I don't know um I
would assume that from Imaging data we
would have the shape of the heart and um
the question would also be how sensitive
is the solution to the shape of the
patient is it possible to use a generic
shape that represents most patients or
that adapts slightly um to the Imaging
data
um I I'm not sure how how the anatomy
would influence uh potential Solutions
those Imaging data is going to give you
the shape of the internal structure of
the heart as well for each patient yeah
yeah sure um we we would have MRI data
or or gener we have MRI data or
ultrasound data even though ultrasound
has a pretty low spatial resolution it's
possible to to extract at least the the
global shape of The ventricle from it
with the at it's a bit more tricky but
um that's definitely possible you
wouldn't be able to extract you know
finer structures especially on the endoc
card um and it's also sometimes not easy
to uh delineate the the organ boundaries
but overall we can definitely see
differences in in in anatomy across
patients and
ultrasound one of the techniques you you
um showed was um you know only the using
the the surface data and well I mean
first you use the computational 3D
computational model and then generate
the data and uh train the unit uh for
example and then once the unit is
trained you just you
know um get the measurement in in sparse
way like you had a some particular shape
of the measurement the location the
space on the surface one was the the
uniform is uh distributed and the other
one was
some how how should I say you know the
straight line to to the center um yeah I
think you mean the uh catheter mapping
data right that's
that's that was a study
um can I go back yeah yeah if you can go
back
see
to the
slide basically my question is how how
do you write like the Circ last you mean
this the star shape at the bottom right
one yeah exactly how how do you choose
that location is is it somewhat flexible
to choose those locations of the
measurement in in this is completely Det
by the manufacturer of that um catheder
so the study here um by by roon at I um
she there I think either chose generic
representations of which like these
geometers are similar to these uh
catheters or they are directly somehow
created from the catheder I don't know
um but there are either these pentay
cathedr or these lasso cathedr and then
also basket Cath catheters those are
just different types of catheters that
are on the market um some of them have
up to 64 I think electrodes the the
basket catheters not all of them measure
something at the same time but they can
sense which ones uh contribute to the
measurement and there are often many
different electrodes that that record at
the same time so that's where it comes
from um and in our study we just used a
something that looks like a star got it
and and I think um in another point of
your presentations you you talked about
the training the unet and then use the
trained unit to um you know get the
information about the inside not not
just the surface I mean the measurement
is done the on the surface but the also
the inter internal yeah yeah this year
yeah right um so this is um we pretend
that this is a piece of the ventricular
wall it's of course heavy really
oversimplified but um uh we were simply
interested is from a from a dynamic
systems perspective is it possible to
reconstruct very chaotic wave patterns
in 3D in 3D from only surface
measurements umre which is a situation
which we have in our lab we can
currently really only measure the outer
surface the AP card but in principle you
can also measure from the inside um the
indoc card at the same time so you have
two cameras for instance facing each
other and in between is the hard wall
and in that scenario you have two
measurements like here on this slide and
then whatever happens within the hard
wall the question was can we recover
that from only these two surface
measurements and based on what we what
we've learned in these two studies here
Stanger and and labor from
2023 it is possible to some extent in in
this scenario like a once step you
Network the neural network is
trained after that is
trained um for the inference stage do
you assume that the whole surface image
is available as an input or only the you
know sparse data on the surface is
available uh here we assume that the
entire surface is available because the
um scenario that we tried to
recapitulate was Optical mapping so
Optical measurement we added some noise
to it and so it also works with noise no
problem but we didn't try out the sparse
measurement so that would be the next
step to uh move to more realistic
geometries um and add
sparcity okay great I mean we have we
have some technology of you
know you know enabling that actually um
you know once you trained up like Auto
encoder or unet and then and only we get
the sparse data on the surface and then
try to reconstruct the whole
3D output data maybe yeah I can
introduce to you yeah that great yeah
after the talk um yeah okay well that is
my question I don't want to take whole
time of the Q&A sessions um is there any
questions from
audience I have a billion questions but
it'll give weeds only one or two allowed
but uh how much luck have how much luck
have you had with phase singularities
every time I've tried to track phase
singularities in cardiac tissue like
it's super messy to do abolutely we yeah
we just gave up and started like just
tracking wavefronts and measuring them
as like a 4D surface instead yeah but
yeah like wander so much and depending
on like little tiny things they're very
sensitive to error and they kind of go W
wobbly all over the place and then
disappear and reappear like continuity
of facing has always been really
difficult for us yeah absolutely I agree
um so there are multiple factors that
that influence that so the noise and and
notional artifacts and and Optical
recordings at least they can cause you
know facing lers to jump or disappear or
something you have spurious facing lers
that are not real um that are just a
result of the filtering so we we have a
protocol I can send it to you if you
want that Works relatively well when the
signal quality is good enough um so you
can um process video data in a way that
you focus on the wave front rather than
the wave itself um both way works and
you have to slightly smooth the data and
then you um remove outliers uh from the
normalized data so what you want to do
is you want to normalize each times
years to amplify the waves and then use
the hi transform or or whatever you you
need in order to embed this this signal
and compute the face map from it and
then what is very important is to smooth
the face Maps using a complex filter so
you you convert the face Maps into a 2d
Vector field with with a normalized
amplitude uh like a you know complex
number and then uh filter that and with
that Technique we had we're quite like
it's pretty robust of course it doesn't
prevent you from detecting face
singularities that are you know further
down further Upstream in the processing
pipeline created there or just simply
the fact that you're looking at a
projection of a 3D wave pattern and
these some of these spiral waves they
Meander really strongly they they have a
linear core rather than
a a point around which they rotate and
that can also cause issues and there's
some work by a group in Belgium that
came out recently where they look at
that in more
detail but it can get very messy yes
have you ever seen an arhythmia without
a um phase Singularity either linear
core or Point
core um I know data from Flavio Fenton
where he he has shown that I think um
have I seen that in my
experiments I don't think so okay cuz we
I've been we've been like saw it all the
time in simulation it would happen
especially around scar structures and
like the whole pH Singularity stuff just
really kind of broke down because
they're like we can't find we have to do
integrals over like half the heart we
can't find the the face singularities
yeah yeah the linear core is really an
issue and and that has also raised
concerns whether this concept of facing
lar even makes sense so the people in
Belgium Hans Dirks and and his people
they they published something last year
I think where they expand this concept
of face Singularity into different lines
and and it gets also really complicated
highlighting that it is a complicated
topic more complicated than at least
just points looking at
points I think it's it's a nice concept
to to to to look at but I would not
overemphasize it to describe
fibrillation in the end it was supposed
to um um reduce complexity if you look
at a three-dimensional wave pattern that
changes quickly in time so a 4D wave
pattern it can become very you you lose
track of it it's it's just complicated
and difficult to understand and
therefore I thought back then in the
2000s it
was thought to to help people to
understand what's going on and in a way
it it helps because you can count the
number of waves you can determine the
density of these waves you can see how
waves interact with each other these
filaments when they touch each other and
break up that's that's a nice concept
but other than that it's I think we also
need other tools to look at C
[Music]
figuration great I mean I I I see that
you you're using um unit or Auto encoder
type of appro that is nice because it
gives you some reduced Laten space
dimensions and um you know bring the
data size effectively reduced to the the
small dimensions and but have you tried
to actually interpret that any physical
meaning on that latent space the reduced
Dimension uh like the in the middle of
the unit or the middle uh space in the
auto encoder um do you mean if you have
ever used visualization tools of what's
going on in the lat space or Well
Physical yeah yeah physical principle
like the I mean you're underlying
physics is Electro mechanical systems
there's you know I I saw you presented
some partial differential equations
associated with it and you know um of
course the data is you know if you use
the simulation um the data will be
really high dimensional so after the
auto incoder it is reduced and you know
it's it's it's quite unknown what
physical meaning those latent space has
you know maybe you can put some meaning
to it physical meaning to it um
associated with those electrical
mechanical electric electric mechanical
system um you have um have you tried
that no we we haven't that we we we try
to kind of verbally you know tget out
what what what happens in the latent
space Maybe here in particular with
these face singularities which is a
simple I think a much simpler problem
where you only have a a scalar valued
field that you transform into a complex
field um you have these two numbers that
Define the phase angle um there I would
say yeah relat space what is it it's um
that conversion you know that you do
with the H transform somehow locally
that's it's much more local I think and
in in the in case of the
electromechanics you have long reaching
elastic
effects um so so Global motion I don't
know how it translates um any different
modes of the contraction or of the of
the deformation of the hearts that are
in the Laten space somewhere I mean it's
it's pretty amazing when you look
at um these simulations
here that you can convert something like
this Vector field on the left into a
scalar VAR field with s a complicated
geometry relatively complicated geometry
yeah it's amazing
and
very interesting very interesting yeah
don't know what happens to right um well
in our group we try to um there's a
framework we we develop hold the last
day Laten space Dynamics identification
meaning that so once once you project
those 3D motions uh Vector field into
the latent space through the auto
encoder and you get some Dynamics in the
in the middle latent space and we don't
know what's the equations for that uh
trajectory data so we try to associate
that with a some sort of differential
equations and then try to understand
what the differential equations what
kind of meaning it has um so yeah maybe
I can yeah introduce that to you as well
okay so I have a two to-do list um um
sounds great yeah I would I would love
to talk about that yeah awesome awesome
all right any other question from
audience well if not let's let's thank
our speaker Yan for the wonderful talk
and the interesting talk i' I I learned
a lot and um hopefully we can you know
further um stimulate the uh the
collaboration between Lawrence liore and
the UCSF yeah would be great I was very
happy when I found out about the seminar
so it was recommended to me by Michael
gravy awesome
awesome thank you thank you
Yan
thanks bye um by